hungary has become a place of absolute
humiliation for the Syrian people and
for the other people trying to reach
asylum in Europe they are blocked here
they are suffering in the heat we see
children all over the place
collapse in absolute exhaustion we have
been into the detention camps and
they're even more horrific than what you
see here and that's exactly why the
Hungarian authorities are keeping the
media out people are kept in tents like
animals out in the Sun without food and
water without any medical assistance
when they get sick it's simply
unacceptable that people are being
treated like animals on the doorstep of
Europe